here what I'm 29 29.
how old are you two he's 22 though
I'm 24. okay
[Laughter]
I'm just thinking because you're you're
29 if you're in a relationship like do
you want kids yes um do you don't have
any kids so you know if you're single by
30 your chance of having a child drops
below 50 so you're actually more likely
you to not have a kid than have one and
by 34 your chance of having like any
kids at all like geriatric pregnancy
working is like nothing it's like yeah I
see it's pretty scary so it's like
I said I know the good eyes
because I'm assuming you're picky right
uh to find like picky like I think I
have my standards I don't think I ask
for anything too crazy I just want a guy
that's like serious about me has pure
intentions for me and will be loyal well
I'm just thinking because you've been
dating since we're 18. yeah 20. yeah
right 20. okay so like I'm just thinking
of nine years if none of the guys that
approached you you like enough to marry
like you're probably picky oh right
this is just me like usually that women
that are single over the age like
they're 25. it's not an insult you know
no no no I think to be honest I'm a
Christian and I think that that makes
things a bit harder for me because
there's certain things that I'm like
that I want to do to please God or
there's some some views that I have that
are more like biblical than like the
world and I think that now I used to
date guys that were non-christians but
the things that I was passionate about
the values that I had they didn't share
those same values and I want to be with
someone that shares those same values as
me and has the same world for you as me
so now that's kind of narrative it's
just him being a Christian no I mean he
has to be a Christian of course but
there's just certain things that like
I've realized are my deal breakers like
what are you on the waiting until
marriage type I mean yeah I'm not I'm
not perfect but that's definitely a
desire it's a desire to want to wait
until marriage yeah okay but you're I'm
assuming 29 I'm not a virgin I'm not a
virgin
I mean yeah that's the type of world
that we're living in it's definitely a
desire I'm not saying it won't happen
but it's a desire and I would like to
stick to that because I guess in my head
I'm like okay so if you're 29 you know
that by now now you know at least that
if you're single by next year you're
most likely not going to have a kid
ended by 34 your chance of having a kid
is basically nothing like biologically
so I'm just thinking if you get into a
relationship with a guy that you like
which I'm assuming is very hard to find
a guy that meets all your criteria
because I mean me too it's not you're
not not just you because I'm thinking
like if you get to that point it's kind
of like your last
chance in a way and then you and then
you leave it over what a message
it's like I would think in the grand
scheme of things it would be more
important to have a family to you
especially you know they say like be
fruitful and multiply in the Bible yeah
but I think for me it's also very
important to be in a situation that is
healthy and I would rather be single
than be in a relationship where I'm not
valued or where I'm being disrespected
or where the duties emotionally or
sexually cheating yeah sometimes I just
Church like leaves women single and I
think it's really sad because I think
sometimes they tell women like we have
to have these crazy high standards yeah
yeah I think that the church you know
that's not that crazy but I think the
church does need to do a better job with
teaching young Christians like how to
date like I go to an amazing church and
it's I'm learning now like through I go
to the tab London and my pastor is is
amazing and he just recently done a
sermon on dating and like how to date
you know you know for marriage with the
intention of marriage and it was very
healthy and very informative would would
you submit to your husband for
everything
but the thing is like with me choosing a
husband I'm gonna choose somebody that I
respect I'm going to choose somebody
that loves God and for me submission is
about if he submitted submitting to
Christ I'm low-key submitting to Christ
if I'm submitting to my husband so then
why did you say no but it's like to me
submitting I think I need to learn about
that more I'm definitely my own woman
but I think it depends in like in what
degree like in what situation do you
follow the Bible
I try well no it just it confuses me
when like that can become one in the
Bible they say the same thing you have
to submit in the Bible
I think it just confuses me like when
you say you want a Christian man but you
don't want to live in a Christian way so
like why would a man that's super
Christian want to be with you if you
don't want to live in a Christian way
which is biblical but what do you mean
by not living in a Christian way so and
the Bible says you have to submit to
your husband and when I asked you you
said no yeah but then and but this is
what I'm saying I think in certain
situations I think and how can I word
this in certain situations of course if
the decision that my husband is making
makes sense and that's fine
yeah I don't really know how to just to
explain the thoughts that I'm having
right now you want to submit when you
feel like it
yes
but then the Bible also the thing is the
Bible does instruct women with like how
to act in marriage but then the Bible
also instructs men with how to treat
their wives as well and so like the
Bible says to women like respect your
husbands and husbands love your wives
and so I feel like yeah but how are we
supposed to get a Christian guy if we
can't start with what we have to do yeah
folks you know like yes I'm just I'm
just you know because you want to start
a family yeah so I'm just wondering how
this should work out go ahead is it an
issue of knowing so you said about the
whole decision thing
um which logically makes sense so like
if he's saying something and you don't
I'm just guessing right if he says
something and you don't know why is your
point you want to know why and if it
makes sense to you then you agree and
that's your version of submitting yeah I
think and that's the thing my thing is I
think that a marriage there's going to
be a lot of like complexities and like a
lot of different situations that we're
going to face in marriage it's going to
be a learning curve it's going to be
like a journey and I think that also
with whatever the Bible does say the
Bible also teaches about like
sanctification and about like a journey
of becoming more like Christ so I'm not
saying that I'm perfect but I'm saying
hopefully me and my husband will get to
a point where you know we're on the same
page and I think yeah you don't believe
like going with the flow no no but God
don't don't say no because going with
the flow could be the best thing the
reason why I say going with the flow you
could be dating you could be on Tinder
whatever and someone could say what are
you looking for right and I could say
for me as a 33 year old I want a child I
want a child but I don't have a if God
blesses me with a child I get blessed
with a child I'm not religious in any
way shape or form but I believe in in
Almighty my thing right now when I meet
girl or a guy and they say like what
you're looking for to say look like my
portfolio would say like I want kids
soon blah blah blah but I'll just say
look I'm just here going for the flow
but I'm looking for a a serious
individual and I would elaborate on that
situation but like when I say I'm going
with the flow doesn't mean I want to
marry you or date you I just want to
chill with you and see where things go
so there is no expectations on either
side you know what I mean it's just
about getting to know the person getting
to know the person but I feel like if
you're with the whole Christian thing
um hats off to you
um
I feel like for guys it can be a bit
intimidating and we don't know where to
start and we're like oh okay you know
what I mean baby you say like Glenn
others are Super Chat says there's no
exception to submission in the Bible
where it says to only submit to your
husband when you want to it says for
everything because you've got to choose
a man that you trust to lead right and
then you've got to listen to it you've
got to submit to because it's as simple
as that because sometimes you can ask
like at the end of the day if you really
are submitting to your husband you're
trusting that they know what they're
doing they're handling things so any
decision they make you shouldn't even be
questioning it anyway because you should
trust them enough to know that they've
already thought that through so you
don't have to so by asking questions
you're kind of creating problems for him
for having to explain it all through to
you and then also you're potentially
causing another problem by then putting
up a barrier if you don't agree with
something that he's done like to me I
would rather leave him with it he says
we're doing something fine I trust him
enough that he knows what he's doing and
he's doing that for our best thing look
at team sports here let's say imagine
Alex Ferguson's your manager and then
he's like cool this player is going to
win after the champions league and we're
like actually and you got this one
brother that's always always uh nah I'm
the manager yeah I'm here to do a job
trust I'm gonna lead and we'll go if you
find a man that keeps leading you into
the into the darkness then that's not
the man for you I guess in it but you
gotta you gotta be on that journey and
actually accept that call I've chosen
this person I just thought of a question
do you think it it is unbiblical if
women don't have children
oh because the Lord because the Lord the
God says to be fruitful and multiply
right and right now women are 100 in
control of who's born so like sex and
reproduction because we're the only ones
that can have a choice in abortion
um and the way the laws are set up like
we're 100 in control so is it unbiblical
if women don't have kids a woman should
be in full control is her body and what
she wants to no I'm not I'm not asking
I'm not asking a question like okay
um I can gossip and I'm in full control
if I want to gossip or not but it's
unbiblical of me to gossip I think
anyways I think of a woman I think if a
woman can have kids she should have kids
that's just my opinion so I'm just yeah
it says to be free from multiplayer so
yeah you're right and also for people
who are believers Christians it is still
their responsibility to go and preach
the word and and do anything to do see
this is this is where I come because I
was gonna I was going to come to your
appointment because I'm also a Christian
right so I I believe in a lot of the
same passages
so for the first because I have two
things for the first thing was to your
point about submission
now as a follow-up question when we say
submit to God does that mean like what
does that mean because then we have to
think about the words that we're using
because we use those words in
Christianity already right when we say
we need to submit to Jesus we just
submit to God submit to the word of
Christ right
that same submission and the
understanding of what it means to submit
to Christ in that same vein obviously
it's not the same because the person
you're submitted to isn't Jesus I'm not
trying to equate them but it's this very
similar vein of like you wouldn't like
like you like you said you wouldn't
question what's coming next if you were
100 submissive now understanding who to
be submissive to is very very difficult
because there are a lot of Snakes in the
Grass there's a lot of people who show
one thing show one hand and actually are
another like like we were saying before
but the actual Act of to say I would
only submit in a certain in a certain
situation which is not what you said but
it's like what it sounds like sounds
like don't you think it's I don't think
it's that difficult to be honest what do
you mean like I I don't think it's
like we kind of like as women like we
act like there's so many men that are
cheating and doing all this stuff but
most men can't do that yeah it's true
like I think there's a lot of average
guys like as women we can date that
wouldn't actually I don't think it's
that crazy this is not but what I'm
saying is in the sense of like I'm I'm
taking it back to the biblical the
biblical sense of submission and the
submission that God has told us to do to
his people and for for him and his son
Jesus right so we understand as
Christians what submission is
but when it comes to submission using
submission to man it becomes slightly
different to Jesus yeah I think there's
just been a breakdown in trust but yeah
right now that's what I'm saying you
know what I mean so with like women
don't really trust families
you know our Glenn says no it's not
unbiblical because there are women who
are born that don't have the ability to
have kids okay
um would you have an issue submitting to
your boss
for you someone asked me
[Music]
um
yes there has been times with past
managers where I think that they're not
always making the right decision okay
and so but I think that I do believe in
just creating that space that respectful
safe environment where I can voice my
opinions they can voice theirs and then
we can just have that conversation
because I think that even if you're my
boss it doesn't mean that like you can't
take on good advice or like do things in
a different way so I think I think I can
submit but I believe in being vocal do
you know how tiring that is as a boss
though
oh my gosh if I told my editor edit the
video this way and every single time I
gave him something he's telling me the
way he wants to do it do you know how
annoying that is no I mean it's not it's
not a case away you've got nothing done
seconds I've got a problem
a couple of situations in the past I
believe in being vocal I believe in
being vocal I believe in creating that
safe space to have a conversation with
the person once they've got all of the
information then they can make their
decision
um away Glenn says a way to look at
submission is like this I will always
respect and submit to the president even
if I don't like him I am submitting to
the position that he holds Danny said
this is for get Pearl the summer AC
funds yo yeah we do need summer we need
AC in here oh [__] does that make sense
to you that what he said yeah that's
very powerful yeah
um no I I don't think you're like I
think a lot of times in the church they
don't really talk about submission it's
odd like not not in the true sense they
do in the sense of like submitting to a
higher being and it's been to like the
will of God and the will of the the
Bible itself but like interpersonal
submission not too much they mention it
it gets mentioned but it doesn't get
like delved into it like great detail
outside of like God man submit to him
and that one gets fleshed out more than
man to man if that makes sense
yeah I think I think there's a lot of
selective politicking with when it comes
to religion so 100 and I think
everyone's out here they're they're
beating they're enjoying life they're
drinking they're doing the thing and
then it's traditional in a sense when
you need to do this so listen later when
it suits you when it suits you yeah
I'm just gonna hit the point and say
that they don't mention it because the
majority of uh churchgoers are now women
and they're catering to women so if
they're pre-submission you're not going
to get much of an audience really damn
there you go the church has been very
feminized wow
I mean why do you think they have like
gay flags in the church now no yeah
[Music]
they're pushing that that's why no no no
no no no no no no no no but is that to
do with remember it's got to do with
fitting in like the whole lgbtq plus I
can't remember the whole name yeah
um it's like a it's like a common thing
now it's like it's a big thing now so
it's like it will like businesses will
now push it and say we support this
because it brings like publicity and
sells or whatever whatever you do or
whatever I know me and I know many
people that are gay or whatever many of
us don't give a damn
I didn't even know we had Flags you know
what price two of my mind and imprints
at all and they asked me my opinion on
something I said bro I didn't even do
you telling me more about the community
than me I said I don't even know I said
okay bring up lgbtq plus plus
uh blessing can you play one of the
videos I was gonna get the reaction to
it I'm gonna read the first I think I
missed one or two super chats I'm gonna
go and get them
um all right guys make sure you like the
video that's the most important metric
did you want Facebook uh you can just
pick one they're all they're all
um
hold on guys um also guys if you have
any questions for the panel make sure
you send it via Super Chat uh okay I
read that one read that one
uh
I read that one okay red
Clan 90.
hey um shout out to Dallas y'all a
little translation for you I just get
along better with guys equals three over
at 4 squared pretty sure it's the same
access across the pond as it is here
Barrett women to um like to test men
more men we like to keep it simple as is
there's no tests the truth comes out in
the wash
um uh Xena W Pearl reaction channels are
fake news that is true
um okay Barrett
Church churches are starting to become
part of the world versus being in the
world and not of it they're failing
God's message and their followers uh
okay that's it
you want to play the video
a woman hit the lottery for 1.3 million
dollars right she hid it from her
husband and 11 days later divorced her
husband he found out two years later
from a letter in the mail it was the
lottery company saying do you want to
get the lump sum or do you want to
continue getting the monthly earnings
okay because yeah they didn't like
recognize that they were divorced
because he stayed at that same address
right so he got the letter but they were
divorced at this time two years later
correct but she won the lottery at the
time
married he sued her and for fraud
oppression and Malice ended up winning
100 percent
plus she had to pay the court fees on
her end
what a king
oh no 100 100 oh yeah what'd you guys
think of that she was wrong yeah right
he won he won Batman won don't try it
don't try it she tried it
for a while though I guess if he would
have got some payments monthly until the
letter came through and he realized or
whatever that's crazy because you know
this made national news that a woman was
you know taking all of a guy's earnings
but women do that all the time yeah
no because this this one's funny because
it's a different amount so yeah I know
that's a big amount of money you know
she was taking I need one legally they
want everything as well because only did
he win money not only did she have to
pay the legal fees he also found out the
kind of woman his wife was yeah he won
and he won but that's probably because
I'm guessing he never had any kids with
her if he had kids with her he wouldn't
have been a different situation because
of liability and blah blah blah and
remember what he earns and yeah
I'm talking about 100 I'm saying the
reason why he would have 100 he couldn't
have had you know any liability with her
with with actual kids no that's because
she was lying you know it's interesting
they looked at what happened when like
each sex won the lottery and the
probability of divorce and how do you
think it turned out
yeah yeah it was like the majority of
the men's state from the majority of the
women but see that that goes to show who
who is responsible with the power of
Leverage
elaborate so the power of Leverage you
being the breadwinner you having a
life-saving amount is that something
that you're going to want to push into
the tree that you already have or is
that something that you're gonna go and
want to do like more selfish things and
go and you know do something independent
you know I mean because bearing in mind
in that marriage you'll have gone
through things where you're both broke
you're going through things you know I
mean not even like a yo I want a lottery
but here take that this is my money but
boom here take that or and another
nothing like that just just up and left
I couldn't imagine if you know I'm
married my wife divorces me then I see
her in
the
idea that men will leave you for a
younger woman before like no fault
divorce was introduced isn't even
correct even before no fault divorce
like women would still leave men more
like they always have right I see that
being true I didn't know that wow yeah
because a lot of people no because it's
a propaganda campaign because basically
um with the women's suffrage movement
they just put like all of this
propaganda in the media to like take men
out of the home basically and tell women
that like we need a career more than we
need back but then again you need to
look at this so men are proposing
sometimes it's not really
I don't know it's the guy that's made
that big decision sometimes the girl
might be like yeah your boyfriend
material but I didn't want to break up
with you but now we're married
and I didn't really think I'd spend the
rest of my life I've dated a lot you
know what I mean but now we're married
things have just moved faster than I
really cared for them to at the time I
thought I'd just go with the flow and
I'm comfortable and they might not
actually think boom like this is not
even the I might grow out of love with
this person but for the guy because he's
making all these
um intentional move movements with you
of course it makes a no-brainer well I
got more money to do things boom yeah
Let's Stay Together I also think maybe
like I don't I'm just guessing here but
going with your scenario I feel like
maybe women sometimes like
they just want a wedding day like they
don't want a marriage they just want a
wedding day someone proposes oh I
couldn't do this
[Music]
so you know it makes sense I had this
conversation with a friend the other day
on gay weddings and I said um and I said
I understand why a woman want to get
married because the whole bridesmaids
and the whole world I said why why men
would want to marry another man that's
just a waste of money and time and the
guy said oh yeah blah blah blah man I
have every right I weren't trying to say
men don't have right to marry another
man I'm just trying to say I understand
why a woman wants it but I don't
understand why a man would waste is that
Marion how do you know what the man it's
intentional like you said you know
because there's so much more especially
in this day and age now and the climate
that we're living in there's so much
more at risk for the guy like that that
is a clear signal from the man that he
is committing to you because you know
and then if you're a girl
and you then just sort of just say yes I
can see it happening would you guys get
married without a wedding
no no yeah what's the point you wouldn't
no why just because
I think it's such a and I'm not one of
those girls who's like dreamed of this
big white wedding my whole life like I
still don't really know too much where I
want my wedding and stuff but I think
it's just a nice way to just bring
everyone that you love and share that
special memory with them to be honest